today on our show man who created the
Joker we all think we know but I think
we found a mystery on the back of an old
comic book page this is something out of
a comic book ladies and gentlemen sit
around and talk to the one man who
discovered perhaps the real secret
origin of the Joker today on fat man on
Batman
welcome to Batman Batman I'm Kevin Smith
mark Barden out here tonight ma'am but
that's okay because we've got a story
for you kids you might have heard this
if you listen to the fat man I'm Batman
podcast we did an audio version of it
very very long as like to our
conversation when the greatest podcast
is I've ever recorded podcast is one of
the greatest podcasts I've ever recorded
in stuff
do yourself a favor go listen to it but
a lot of people online were like we want
to see this [ __ ] pages and stuff so
this is the forum for that kind of thing
welcome to fat man I'm Batman
Matt Kennedy go to a 2-shot over here
that's a single there you go suza this
is Matt Kennedy now a lot of people like
who's Matt Kennedy Matt Kennedy is very
important individual man he's done a
[ __ ] [ __ ] ton of things he's my
spiritual brother from another mother
man he has lived many lives before we
get into the key pieces of what we're
gonna talk about today give him your
geek bona fides like how you got to this
moment in time because got a lot this is
good go okay so I'm the galley gallery
director of la luz de zeus gallery in
Los Angeles which is the gallery they've
started a lowbrow movement and pop
surrealism away like everyone knows the
lowbrow move in the pop surrealism tell
them what that is so it's if you're
familiar with people like Mark Ryden or
Robert Williams and the guy who did the
cover to Appetite for Destruction that
all grows out of the zap comix
underground comic movement and
tattooists and animators and we were the
first gallery truly showcased that and
we became you know abacus with that for
20 years or so and I will be celebrating
our 30th year this year 30 years of this
gallery Luz DeJesus is one of the
premier if not the premier [ __ ] art
gallery for me in Los Angeles is you
know there I'm sure there are more
cultured or what would you call them I
am and show this to me [ __ ] highbrow
yeah yeah I guess this the art that they
sell out let loose days Suze there's a
picture of the place man it's wacko they
call it soap factory that's a store that
you could buy a bunch of [ __ ] cool
[ __ ] and but in the back there's the
gallery itself we actually shot there
recently for this pilot thing we did
called Halloween but I've been going to
this gallery forever I've so much [ __ ]
artwork from this so you've been working
with these cats for how many years I
started in 1991
yeah but I went into entertainment for a
very long time Tom how okay so I was
working register at a soap plant which
was then on Melrose I was like 1990 this
one we just showed is on been there for
20 years but I was working register and
Mel Brooks just kind of walked in him a
single is a great story single for the
story so Mel Brooks came into the the
store just to open up the door and
pointed at me and said him and then went
went away and I didn't recognize him at
first and this woman came in after him
and said oh yeah are you free in half an
hour for an hour because mr. Brooks
liked to shoot with you and I told her
I'd love to but I'm working and the
manager at the time who was also my
roommate said you have to go she's like
I'll find somebody to cover for you but
you have to go do this this is Mel
Brooks I was like that was Mel Brooks we
shot like a commercial for his Robin
Hood Men in Tights arguably the worst
Mel Brooks movie but I was happy as a
clam so you were hired to do what you
were a guy who's like I just saw this
movie or something no they put together
groups of different types of people and
I was like part of the punk rock heavy
metal kids and we were walking down the
street singing where men were men in
tights
you've been directed by Mel Brooks yes
how was that man it was cool he's fast
and efficient
yeah and that actually led to me being
an actor for years like quite
accidentally and I had not thought about
it for a while and then went with a girl
that I knew I was also working in a bar
at the time and her boyfriend had scored
a movie that a friend of mine had
produced and it was Natural Born Killers
and so we went and saw a friend was
bombed on Murphy Murphy yeah producer
yeah prefer the dauber people do for
producer of of Natural Born Killers and
a lot of things yeah pupil from hell yes
I mean now the the Transformers films
that's right yeah yeah yeah so wait so
he said come he brought you what was it
he had produced the film with jane
hampshire at the time and gotten on the
script to oliver stone he bought the
tarantino script right and I think he
put David Vilas or somebody on on the
rewrite and it it got made it was queued
up for Oliver Stone and back then he was
like go I've got three movies ahead and
like no you have to make this next and
he's like okay and I ended up going to
the premiere because I knew them and
afterwards this girl had a casting
session and so I just went with her and
I got tired waiting around so I signed
in and I just booked this job with Moshe
Baraka who had you know taking pictures
of Janis Joplin and the Beastie Boys and
Hendrix and then I end up getting her
agency and and going out on a lot of
calls and I acted for quite a while you
know what [ __ ] Forrest Gump do I know
I'm the Forrest Gump of um culture pop
culture in Los Angeles cuz take him back
to the comic book store like tell him
where you worked so that was fantastic
store comics which is where it was on
Highland and right above Hollywood
Boulevard and I worked with Gaston
Dominguez who would later open up
meltdown comics meltdown for those who
go to a two-shot that were single
whatever the [ __ ] those that don't know
melt it how can you not just enter
meltdown comics in Google and see is one
of the premiere [ __ ] comic book
stores on the planet and what's the do
his name Gaston Gaston yeah great [ __ ]
dude the he worked with you yeah and
then one day was like I'm gonna open my
own shop yeah I I quit first and but it
was also the shot that they shot true
romance at the fan it wasn't called
fantastic fantastic so that's where the
so the scenes and true romance were
there in the comic store that's
fantastic cyst at all no not anymore it
was a black building with like the thing
from the Fantastic Four word hanging
over it and it was kind of a dump but it
was kind of a great shop and it was in
it once exactly once in my life I think
circa nineteen like 96 when I was dating
Joey Adams like one day I drove past it
was a holy [ __ ] because I knew of this
is even pre meltdown I think I knew of
course Golden Apple yeah and hidey-ho
and Santa Monica and house the secrets
but this one like was this looked like a
New York hole in the wall
bookstore yeah I remember going in and
being like oh my god this [ __ ] place
is the test never went back and stuff
and then one day it was closed yeah it
doubled for Detroit so I mean to it yes
and I love Detroit but the UM
they shot there they shot Raji so when
he walks out of the bedroom it's
supposed to be above the comic shop it's
actually the original Raji's which was
taken down in the 92 quake oh um yeah so
I I did the set design inside the comic
shop for them and I thought that because
it was Warner Brothers production it was
going to be Batman but they called this
the day before and said no it's all
spider-man and so I just did a
spider-man waffle [ __ ] weird dude so
when you watch that movie or like I did
that yeah alright nobody cares alright
so you have this weird wonderful life
where'd you come from originally tell
him that I'm originally from Lynn
Massachusetts ok mass whole total mass
total mass and what brought you out to
California I crashed my car in the snow
and I'm like I am out of here and I was
like I'm gonna go be a rock star in LA
and move was that music music was yeah
yeah
so picture me like probably 40 pounds
lighter and with long you know Axl Rose
hair and I moved out with with my best
friend since kindergarten kid named Todd
Harvey and we we came out together and
he got he got into a band really quickly
and I played with a couple of bands on
one which got signed and we had a
terrible name was called abusement Park
amusement park got a medal yeah and they
went through a bunch of lineup changes
after I left and actually got signed and
did some soundtrack work I think I'm
like Road rules or something but um in
that time I discovered that I was I was
much more drawn into what I was finding
out about the the LA art scene and even
about Hollywood and so I just kind of
drifted in that direction hmm and it was
cool you know I I ended up after I quit
at fantastic store I went down to Tamara
Louis with a friend of mine and he's
like oh you know you're always talking
about art you should check out this
place and I went in there was a Joe
Coleman show was up and I had seen a Joe
Coleman show at in Boston and just
caught the tail end of it but missed all
the mayhem
and this this great girl who was behind
the counter who was is like 1991 and she
had like full sleeve tattoo and she was
gorgeous
which now you'd walk or you see somebody
in tattoos yeah whatever but 1991 II
like your exotic where are you from I
mean I've never seen it before and she
was really really nice
and um that they had put a tarp up
because the show was coming down and she
let me go see it and all the pieces were
off the wall but on the floor and I
could see this joke home in paintings
I've never seen in person before and she
told me that there was this event that
was that night and I went down to the
the pier in Santa Monica because she
told me that's where it was and I just
you know got on a bus and waited you
know and kind of didn't know exactly
where it was but I figured it out and
people that were there were like Robert
Williams and you know Billy Shire who
owns those days who since started wacko
and the next day after that performance
where Joe blew himself up on the pier
basically um he's more he'd set
explosives under his chest then just
like light them off like during a
performance piece okay yeah I mean I
wouldn't have done it yeah I know all
right but still anything for an audience
yeah we finish yeah so the next day I
went back to that shop and asked for a
job application and I got hired in the
bookstore which was then called so plan
and it was right in the corner of
Melrose in Martel and I worked there
because two other guys that worked there
were from Lynn and they thought I was
kidding like who told you to write Lynn
the application you're also from
Massachusetts yeah don't you know who'd
you go to school with you know and I had
the same friends that this kid had
before he moved so how we're all small
[ __ ] world kismet yeah so you start
working at La Luz at that point yeah
what year is that
like 91 and they were there for how long
on Melrose um he had billy had moved
from from Los Feliz and Silver Lake in
1980 I think and Wakko was right next
door to so plant and then he moved he
got a warehouse space a little bit
further down the street and people who
remember classic Melrose
remember there was this like wall of
mirrors that you would walk down this
hallway off Melrose and that's where
Wakko got relocated and then the gallery
went upstairs so you'd walk past the
newsstand on Marteau and up the stairs
and it was
it was like when I first walked in I was
like you knew you're in someplace that
did not exist anyplace else
I mean it was like a little bit of like
Shambhala I mean it was you walk up the
stairs and there was weird symbols drawn
on the stairs and you could smell
incense when you got to the top there
was this counter that had like bones in
it and around the corner was like old
ethnic folk art and things were like I'm
from Massachusetts man this is what I
[ __ ] came here like they say in any
place else this is Los Angeles yeah you
know I was born in Salem and Salem is
which town USA now you know but when
you're not they didn't really wrap their
head around we could be the Halloween
capital of the world until after I was
gone really yeah like they would close
the witch Museum in October because they
thought that the tourist season ended in
September meanwhile it's just like you
guys are party central for Halloween
yeah and now it's it's crazy it's like
Mardi Gras in New Orleans but the UM you
know you'd think that there'd be a
little bit of that that exotic nature
and it was sort of like a little bit of
Crow Haven corner which was like the
official witch of Salem shop and then
everything else that you could imagine
and the bookstore was downstairs and
they had every book that you wanted to
buy and you don't remains that way like
if you go to so plan Wakko la Luz
DeJesus is a singular experience retail
experience you you walk into that store
or the any of that space and you feel
instantly like a kid who's getting away
with something you're seeing something
you shouldn't necessarily see it's not
horrible like a [ __ ] headless
children but it's just all of its just
so like I don't care who you are you
walk in that store you do not feel edgy
yeah you immediately feel lame because
you're just like [ __ ] I thought I was
the edge I'm not the edge I'm a [ __ ]
spoon the edge is all around you in that
place it's very magical yeah like really
like in terms of stores I've been in my
life top 5 in terms of like I could go
back every time I go back to something
new yeah it's always something worth
buying and even if you're like all right
I bought all the crap boom there's a
gallery show see you right in the back
so you can go buy something that don't
have a red tag on and the a beautiful
[ __ ] pieces back when I first got
hired there I mean two of my co-workers
were Holly Woodlawn who just passed away
holy [ __ ] really Holly was working at
whack
with gorilla who is actually another one
of the Andy Warhol Superstars and I had
an art project with with gorillas in the
in the 90s doing silk-screening stuff
but silk-screened with a [ __ ] Andy
Warhol vet yeah dude
you are [ __ ] poor Scott
there was an N Scott Weiland and Scott
Weiland was still in mightyjoyoung
really and I'm also recently passed but
yeah but he was a cool fun-loving guy
and I guess he missed a lot of work he
got fired but um he trained me I think
on three departments I took over I think
hair dye and like candles and maybe
ceramics that were his department and I
got brought in to replace him yeah and
it was just like the people that would
walk in were amazing it was like all
your idols would walk in and everybody
from William Burroughs who actually
William Burroughs actually bumped into
me while I was bending over to pick up a
book at Lois day at so plant downstairs
and I was like what the hell and I was
like oh it was William Burroughs oddly
okay that's fine and um you know just
everybody who Steven you know Steve
Perry came in and Axl Rose came in and
had this weird conversation in the shop
and you know what one of the other
places that I was fortunate to work out
later on was Holly booking poster an
amazing goddamn iconic store in this
time and Eric Heiden was was a great guy
one of those masks but yeah it was it
was a great place to be and even at the
time that I was there and I feel like
part of what what I feel really lucky
about is that it wasn't necessarily that
I was at these places but at the times
that I was at these places was when
things were really exciting and like the
indie film explosion was really starting
to happen you know like how Hartley had
been making movies and in the late 80s
and Ted Hope would come in when he was
in town oh yeah and I mean you know you
were you were developing stuff with you
know Miramax and there was a lot of
people like Tarantino was coming in and
I saw that store like
I think that store existed when I first
went to Hollywood when I was a kid and I
remembered it too like when I went back
to Hollywood in the early
nineties and stuff after clerks and that
was one of the first stores that I
sought out anytime I needed a poster
yeah which oddly enough was often he
would go to that [ __ ] store and he
would always gauge your as yourself as a
filmmaker by whether or not your poster
was up on the wall if your movie was
coming out today at everything he's
almost like they got him straight out
the [ __ ] bus stops and stuff I
remember one thing I've always regretted
not buying was a gigantic [ __ ] Batman
Returns Michael Keaton poster the bus
shelter posters yeah well one of them
others went on a rampage about those
like you're working there at that time
yeah tell the story [ __ ] yeah the UM
there were the bus shelter posters which
are kind of like the same size as the
Italian quads they're like four feet by
six feet and um people were stealing
them out of bus shelters for banners
yeah thinking about that and Nightmare
Before Christmas were the two that
really back-to-back just got you know so
many bus shelters got hammered Wow and
they would routinely send people out to
close down shops that were selling them
because they they thought that they were
from the Vandals but honestly most of
those posters came directly from the
printers who made them really they'll
run off extras and bring him in and
stone to shops that make sense of all
the [ __ ] Warner Brothers just like
their Boston bus stops we have to stop
as like now we got them from extras man
that store is [ __ ] amazing you saw a
lot of famous people come to yeah
and as a result of actually working at
the the photo counter there was with
John who's now over at Larry Edmonds
right down the street I would often be
pulling photos for extras on DVDs and
I'd always been interested in that and I
ended up working for Bill Lustig who ran
blue underground at the time he kind of
trained me for what would be my next job
which would be licensing films and it's
something I've always been interested in
I started looking into it and I was sort
of like I was kind of a bootlegger you
know I was like a guy who would buy
Japanese laser discs and bump them down
to videotapes I've seen the director's
cut of doing about a hundred times
because of all the sides I had to flip
yeah there he had to buy this three-hour
you know SP speed
and so it was one of the things that
that you know we did and I like to say
that come from a long line of
bootleggers and pirates the grandfather
who was a bootlegger and there's my
dad's name was Walter this Walter
Kennedy in the in the pirate museum but
maybe there he's like seven seas pirate
the other guy's a bootlegger in here I
am a video pirate yeah I watch movies a
blood suppose yes polish shades but I
got kind of used to seeing what people
wanted to get their hands on so I
started looking into licensing films and
well I was acting I got called out on a
spot for series which was this kind of
Reader's Digest condensed versions of
Troma films and as a result get made
they shot the pilot and it was something
that I read on for a really long time
and they decided to go in a different
direction when they finally went to UM
to shoot it and um but it brought me
into contact with all the Troma people
and I ended up doing a lot of work with
them and and got Romeo and Juliet into
regular release theaters and like not
just this midnight movies it was the
first time a Troma film had gone into
regular release because I promoted the
hell out of it the night cause that
worked out really yeah that's how it
worked
yeah so you know like James Gunn was
either he was but he was still in New
York so I was familiar with what kind of
who he was and I met him once at a
function where Lloyd was out and also
Roger Corman and one of the partners at
at his film company the original company
and there was an award ceremony UCLA and
so I met him very briefly but I
connected with him years later when he
was shooting PG porn in front of
Hollywood poster actually on my way to
work and then he started dating a friend
of mine and we became closer and so I
see him quite a bit the [ __ ] really he's
a great guy he has not changed at all
he's exactly who he is
and he's a really really cool guy he's
super good with fans and I'm completely
happy that the guardians of the galaxy
universe is in his hands because a very
talented writer - yeah
[ __ ] that good he's a good dude I
always liked his work it's real [ __ ]
like weird and wonderful split there and
super special a man is really wonderful
flick alright so here go to two-shot now
we told you all of that just to kind of
set up what we're about to really talk
about the true of the subject matter of
today's show that was just a long way of
saying Amen Matt's been around and he's
got be a geek bona fides and stuff one
of the things he also likes to do
original artwork combo guard were
telling me Jack Kirby stories so I
actually bought my first original
artwork paid published original artwork
page from Steve Bessette when I was like
a 12 year old kid working in a comic
shop set was the swampthing page yeah
Steve Bessette John told have been
worked on Alan Moore Swamp Thing later
on do they work on Rick beaches as well
yeah a little bit I think that I'm
greatest comics ever met Rick came in to
replace Steve but they were you know
we're gonna go they're both from Vermont
that's true and um I'd always collected
comic book art when I could I loved it
on that page actually got stolen at a
convention and you know obviously
haven't found it again either due to be
dead yeah yeah but I started collecting
comic book art in the early 90s when
Gaston and I were roommates and and when
we were still a fantastic store him
before he left to do meltdown and I
helped him do construction on the first
door mhm artists Ross commercial and we
bought entire comic books and glenn
danzig was actually the guy that bought
entire comic books full of artwork
artwork to cover to cover all the
original pages and Glenn gens again a
huge collection of stuff and sometimes
he was like oh you know I don't mind
letting go with this and he he knew what
prices to set stuff at and we had
regular bars for comic book art and
anybody from James Earl Jones to the
Holland brothers who wrote all the
Motown like hits you know
holland-dozier-holland is like on the
publishing for every Motown hit their
office was a block away from fantastic
store and they came in and they bought
sports cards and we converted them over
to buying art pages really you know like
these are fine but like the real moneys
in complication and they were like they
didn't necessarily know the titles but
they were interested in the investment
opportunity they bought a lot of great
stuff
as we were doing this I started
accumulating like pages that I knew I
wasn't gonna sell that were just like I
can't sell this this is too great and
you'd sell stuff to buy more stuff you
know it's like the worst the worst sales
habit of all time you know violating the
law of the street you know don't get
your own supply stuff not to this
[ __ ] so beautiful and you realizing
you're holding a one-of-a-kind piece of
artwork yeah something that like you
know this belongs in a museum you could
frame it and put it up in a house that's
legitimate now yeah 20 years ago people
like what's that now you put it up
people like Jesus Christ let's [ __ ]
class yeah they'll stand in front of
there your your art with their wine
glass but the when I when I started
working and came back to work at la luz
de zeus after being gone you know for
four years and came back as the director
of the gallery and I put together a show
that I spent about three years on but
honestly I spent about twenty years on
it a lot of story of your life yeah and
we love the artwork for the piece for
the what is it called the pop sequential
consequentialism this first picture we
got and so I put together this show and
I realized when I was collecting all the
artwork for the show that these types of
original art pages required a lot more
explanation than paintings that
generally you know you put up the
website or you put a show statement up
for for an artist in a gallery setting
and you get their bio in a little bit of
a show statement but with comic art to
bring my fine art collectors in the
comic art I had to educate them on why
these pages weren't important so then we
did with the Holland brothers right and
so it was you know not necessarily about
the first appearance of a character
though there was certainly some of those
but the importance of collaborations and
to me the the whole pivotal aspect of
the pop sequential ISM show was
collaborations between writers and
artists and why you know it's important
when you've got Garth Ennis you know
working with Steve Dillon on first
Hellblazer and then preacher and I also
wanted to shadow God I [ __ ] forgot
their run on Hellblazer yeah was just
fantastic groundbreaking yes about that
pre preacher yeah and so the the heroic
aspect became my focus and I always felt
like superhero comics didn't get the
respect that they deserved as art pieces
and certainly there were people that
were
he's starting to respect people like
Jack Kirby and and Steve Ditko and and
even Neal Adams and John Besh Emma but
you know in the early 90s when we were
buying preacher pages at Comic Con for
60 bucks I bought some of those big ya
from Steve Doan it was a whole different
world and you know back when Jack was
still alive Glenn Danzig had introduced
us to his work and his availability and
let us know that you know he just lives
out in Thousand Oaks he can just give
him a call and I did I got the number
from Glenn and I called up Jack Kirby
and Jack give him a single this man
talking Jack Kirby go ahead so I called
up Jack and um hello I was like hiya my
name is Matt Kennedy I got over from
Glenn Danzig and I'd like to buy some
comic book art and he was like okay come
on over you know and so I did I took
three buses to to his house because I
don't have a car and I brought my my
checkbook and my wallet and he had
gotten back all the pages that Marvel
had never released to him just recently
and if you remember the old eclipsed
comic books all the back covers and
while the eclipsed comic books had a
picture Jack Kirby and it said Marvel is
25th anniversary this year what about
Jack Jack had his arms crossed and he
had kind of a furrowed brow and so all
this stuff was just piled around his his
workstation is his like little home
office and um you know his his wife
answered the door and she made us like
tuna fish sandwiches and I wouldn't look
at the stuff he's like what do you like
Kennedy what do you like that's like Oh
Thor can't have Thor how about this
beautiful Captain America page and out
of nowhere he produces this oversized
Captain America page and it was the
centerfold of the Bicentennial marvel
treasury edition and it's got cap and
every character from Captain America on
it
and um and I use like it's like I'll
tell you what let's play some Checkers
and if you win it's $300 and if I win
it's $400 okay and Jack Kirby cheated at
checkers you heard a noise and I turned
my head his hands are on the board and
then he'd turn around in his arms would
be like folded like a move kid you move
he [ __ ] he
hee hee mesmerised you with Kirby dots
yes [ __ ] win the game zip atone all
over the hood but he actually honored he
won the game and he honor the original
prize and I brought it home in the bus
you know and and realized that you know
that that comic art was really a
unifying thing that you know people on
the bus were kind of like a little
curious like why is this kid holding
this thing mmm this giant drawing and
very carefully and it was like a total
like gangbanger type kid and he came
over he sat next to me he's like he's
like when she got there homes and I was
like oh this is a Captain America page
she was like that's pretty [ __ ] cool
you know and that kind of led me you
know I could do a blanket of security
literally security and it kind of let me
down the road and I started reaching out
to other people who were my heroes but
it really set me up for wanting to bring
this artwork to a wider audience and
those days whose had done that before I
came along you know in 1986 when I'm
Billy set up Billy Shire set up the
gallery he had given shows to people
like Robert Williams and Joe Coleman and
then did this app 13 show when I was
working with him on Melrose as just like
a shop manager not not as a gallery
director and this app 13 show was like
all the classic underground guys so
Robert Crumb you know Moscow so and
Spain and it was just incredible and
superhero comic just didn't get that
respect it's those two never really in
my experience never really crossed off
like it crossed like I remember when I
was a comp of hardcore comic book reader
collector in the late eighties early 90s
like there were wizard people later on
and there were comics journal people
yeah
and those two never really crossed over
CBG comics buyers guy was somewhere in
the middle yeah as a newspaper but
comics journal like they weren't like
[ __ ] superheroes but they're like only
ten people five could do superheroes
anymore and the rest was more about
everything else that wasn't a super
remember amazing heroes
and the pre wizard wizard really and
that was really the divide and I
remember that and I also remember
reading some of those amazed and Gary
Groff you know dia tribes in comics
Journal but he still sort of had a
love-hate relationship with with
superheroes and he would still have you
know Gil Kane interview Robert Crumb or
something like that and so there was
still like a lot of coverage for
superhero stuff and then when they went
to the kind of quarterly perfect bound
version of it it was there was no love
for superheroes I mean the only person
who wrote superhero comics like that
gets covered in the in the Comics
Journal is Grande Morrison and it's
because his stuff is very different and
has that appeal to people who don't like
superhero comics so I put together the
pop sequential ISM show and I realized
I've written like 80 pages of
descriptions because you had to and and
so I thought well I'm not just gonna put
this up online I'm gonna publish this
and so we'd already published 40 books
with love Lou Stacy's press through last
gasp and so we put it out and you know
it's out there in the world and it's
become kind of a price guide for
original comic book art nice I mean get
it at love Lou stays calm any place that
carries last-gasp product they can get
it there there's a pop sequential isn't
calm as well thanks for hanging out with
us here today I'm fat man I'm Batman man
I've been Kevin Smith this is Matt
Kennedy go visit la luz de zeus in los
angeles and come back next one of them
next episode right here same bat-time
same bat-channel
smart guest icon / Kevin Smith
hey Nance me Kevin Smith thanks for
watching do me a favor click that thing
below that says subscribe every time you
click that you save a baby kitten from
murder